after facing the harsh threat of majin
buu lord beerus the return of freedom
and survival of God that was the
universe six tournament the dust had
sent calmness and tranquillity has once
again whole world of Dragon Ball but
that it's time for black y'all and i'm
black y'all and i'm black it is black
and i'm black y'all and i'm black y'all
and i'm black y'all and i'm black it is
black and i'm black y'all i'm pretty
black black black black some planet
black yo because a black gonna breast
now before we get to black y'all i know
what some of you guys might be thinking
TNM what's with all this best animation
stuff don't you always do the worst
first and to answer that question yeah
in truth there wasn't enough poor
animation to warrants an entire video
for this arc specifically but fret not I
haven't forgotten about those bad
moments and I have special plans for
them in the future but for now it's
black y'all and i'm black hey hey I'm
talking here jeez it's time for the top
10 best animatable with the Dragon Ball
super is Future Trunks Ark number 10
Goku vs. fuse de Matsu episode 66
chopping off our list at number 10 comes
one of many eye catching moments from
episode 66 the penultimate episode of
this arc this scene brought to us with
the combined effort of two very talented
artists one of the animation supervisors
for this episode yuuichi Kurosawa and
futoshi he Ishida who handled most of
the key animations in this sequence the
episode opens as we take up right where
we left off from last time on Dragon
Ball super karasawa is felt at the
beginning of the scene his angular line
work with varying degrees of shading
give the characters greater three
dimensionality
getting this episode with tremendous
detail and intensity Goku goes all out
getting the better of the masses holy
wrath what's next or of a resentment
blast of you're not my real mom surge of
I'm sorry ain't you no one understands
me
we're sad so I think we need to workshop
that last one seems a bit long for
practical use in battle
I don't know the mas what do you think
yeah very good
anyway using his trademark coming huh me
huh goku leaves imasu looking like yeah
that Goku quickly and briefly channels
kaio-ken to escape from the Masters
grasp once escaped kick some ass ooh in
the face doing pretty much exactly what
I would do making absolutely [ __ ]
certain that I don't touch any of that
nasty athletes face Tomas Suez but yeah
cusine number 9 Goku vs imasu and black
and family story and probably some other
stuff
this shit's hard to take down episode 61
this episode implements a tried and true
formula that has reared its head
countless times in the franchise loved
one in danger plus being backed up
against the walls
this time literally equals bad time for
bad guy we've seen it a ton in this
series be it go on go on go on
good Gohan Gohan Goku and they say Goku
pull [ __ ] out of his ass
I apologize I'm getting tangential here
point is this is the type of scenes
every Dragon Ball fan lives for calling
upon a deeper strength in vengeance of a
loved one something that's very easy to
follow and admittedly fun to watch let's
break it down
this scene begins with Goku backed up
against the wall facial expressions are
key with the close-quarter scene like
this one i'm masahiro she my new key
doesn't fail in delivering some great
facial expression being its imasu black
or Goku's reaction to being stabbed
black explains to go through that he
kills chichi and ghost and immediately
following the execution of the plan
don't in a very haha take on me sort of
way that surprisingly really worked
Goku then begins to rage and calls these
two baddies all sorts of displeasure
before he doesn't again but before that
the most noble parts include Goku's
initial verse from the wall it's badass
the masu being pummeled through the
floor via ki black Goku's back fist to
saman soo I know it's a little over the
top but come on that's the most
memorable moment from the scene the most
well animated portion of this
however has to be its ending when black
takes control with his new Keyblade kind
of looks like one of those swords Malad
sending shots through the coup
ultimately leading to up yep
really solid seen easily a standard
moment in this art number 8 episode 47
yep
you heard correctly remember in my last
video where I broke down the differences
between the super manga and the anime
series
I said towards the end of the video that
the first chapter pertained to the
Future Trunks art was my favorite
chapter episode 47 aka the animes
introductory episodes the future Trump's
arc was in my view the best episode of
the Dragon Ball super series as a whole
thus far moving with movie level
production forces bottom of course
speaking in broad strokes let's talk
specifics the episode opens with an air
of mystery unlike any episode beforehand
we'll be open with Future Trunks running
from a shadowed pursuer through a ruined
city much like in the manga I'm tired
from instilling the viewer with a much
needed narrative total shift to
something more serious this episode
features some of the best cinematography
any Dragon Ball episode today burning
red ember floating through the air
delicately as the remains of a shattered
civilization surrounds the area in a
haunting green glow taking chances like
killing off former and indication of
Maya's death this all adds a sense of
much-needed despair and gravity to the
episode that honestly had me at the edge
of my seat throughout the entire viewing
building up beautifully to the climax
which features trunks facing off against
what is to be revealed as Goku the
animation throughout is a marvel you can
pick up moments here and there there are
standout animation lines but honestly
it's what the episode does that flies
under the radar that's the most
noteworthy I think it's no katate is
gorgeous action yes but the effects work
cinematography storyboarding and
Composition bills and simply spectacular
atmosphere that makes this an episode
every Dragon Ball fan and critic should
watch it might not demonstrate the best
animation this arc has to offer but it
most certainly is in my view the most
consistent looking episode from start to
finish number seven the Cheatham versus
black at
so 63 coming in at number seven is Goku
blacks final time squaring off against
the Saiyan Prince Vegeta episode 63 the
episode which this scene caps off was
actually overseen by two animation
supervisors Yoshitaka yashima if she
would she Romanov a Yash Elin was given
the talking scenes to take care of
leaving the frankly underrated Minami to
tackle all the action scenes this
episode had to offer and trust me when I
say this guy did a stellar job this
scene in question can actually act as a
personal highlight room for she would
Sherman Ave is capable of slow-motion
wind and dust effects fast and detailed
comic particle effects on points and
photography even a mode of expression
but aside from that I think we can all
agree here that this was a much-needed
show of dominance for Vegeta's character
in his story also from a narrative
standpoint I can see the value in
spacing out of these moments it makes
them mean more standout amidst the long
section of the story but Rita has now
taken a leading role in telling it has
its perks with this however fans were
greeted to a return of form for Vegeta
fresh out of the hyperbolic time chamber
ready to victimize all who stood in his
way he's brash he's a bit of a [ __ ] but
we love him and why because he's Vegeta
the prince of all things number 6 trunks
versus black no not that one you know
the one would like Mayan it says episode
63 on the script light does that help
information he faces black like 20 times
of his arc I mean what do you want
people to do memorize the [ __ ]
episode numbers I don't remember which
one number 63 is and I'm you perturb
after 80 in the getaway of an injured
Vegeta and Goku trunks elects to remain
in the future acting as the Earth's soil
defender against the two disillusioned
deities and if this day wasn't already
[ __ ] enough my goes off with this plan
and with two guys who by all accounts
one to you swimmer the hot beef
injection
yeah I honestly can't believe she
thought this was a good idea after
seeing this but what stretch of the
imagination did you think a strong
bullet could do better because I thought
of what
stronger bullet first the cat food now
this real secure [ __ ] like the toshihiko
shoe day and okay toss a take center
stage in this short but brilliant action
sequence where trunks endeavors to
defeat the combined efforts of both Goku
black and the masu something that both
Goku and Vegeta had failed to do up
until this point in the series moving
along this scene wasn't one that
specifically stood out to me upon my
first viewing many of the entries on
this list that came before this one were
was that I knew would feature in this
list for sure but this one I think is
just better and to think a completely
flew under my radar those of you that
are familiar with my content and this
channel know full well how much no
quítate means to me as an animator
within this company but in the community
people can be quite hum or cold when it
pertains to his work the main
contributor icing for this is that his
work sometimes looks a little more off
model than the works of others for the
sake of better animation in this scene
we get the best of both worlds however
the fluid window works of take' combined
with the sinister and on model
corrections of Higa sheet a who let's
face it control the [ __ ] of a Goku black
combine the forces of no quítate and
hakushi day creates a visual experience
that i think is extremely hard to rival
if you're like me and only vaguely
recall this theme I highly encourage
anyone who is interested in the art of
animation to check this out again
you won't regret number 5 the cheetah in
the gravity chamber episode 52
speaking of hakushi day hearing is again
taking the number 5 spot on our list
this time with a classic gravity chamber
training session with Captain widow's
peak himself Vegeta it's short but man
this one is great and what seems to be a
particularly bad day I mean black sort
of Florida all of his family and friends
I mean that's like a sizeable disc
taking his frustrations out from the
robot and what has to be at this point I
billion times Earth's normal gravity the
jury's still out whether or not that's a
real number but explosion particle
effects some really awesome combat
animation this one is kicked elbowed and
plunge its way onto the list number 4
Goku vs. black episode 50 say that
everything from this entry off until the
top spot is some of the best work the
entire Sirian has produced is an
understatement for there still to be
some people out there spouting the
Dragon Ball super is still some
honest with poor animation is laughable
where it may have struggled in the past
it seems to have found a winning formula
and the first example of what super is
now capable of comes in the first
exchange between Goku and black in
episode 50 people haven't seen this arc
in its entirety will definitely recall
this bliss of animation excellence from
yuuichi Kurosawa who is in my opinion
the new gold standard of Dragon Ball
super animation Department standing in
amongst the other fights in this arc
because it was upbeat scenery karasawa
brings a level of polished a few fight
scenes so far and super have produced I
mean look at the detail and go through
the hair with subtle facial expressions
aerial dodging and some of the
best-looking on model work of the entire
series I can confidently say that
Kurosawa has produced my new favorite
still of our main man G that Don's the
orange key it's details it's beautiful
and it almost took the number three
spots
I absolutely lost in this fight number
three trunks versus fuse the massive
episode 466 controversy aside episode 66
brought us possibly the most jam-packed
episode of the entire series at least
from an animation perspective every
major name from the studio plus more had
a finger in this metaphorical pie this
particular scene combines the efforts of
newcomer Kenji Mumma shuichiro Munnabhai
and no stranger to the top 10 series ken
Otsuka trunks fighting with a new sense
of purpose at the zenith of his powers
clashes with a no salt of slime samatha
viewers animation in this sequence is
nothing short of incredible
lots of action of movement is conveyed
in long tracking shots giving this a
distinctive feel to the rest of the
episode mr. Bernardo turns up in the
middle to add a much-needed sense of
despair to the fight using his sinister
artwork banaba worked so well with these
quote-unquote evil characters his use of
angular facial expressions truly as to
every villain he's got ended just look
at it
the shit's terrifying it's amazing oh
Ken Asuka brings a scene home with some
of the best artwork of the episode this
close up of trunks in particular is my
favorite still from the fight this scene
also has my favorite quote from the
episode - I won't lose to someone who
can't believe in anyone for themselves
the thought process the masu had while
radical had its point humans by nature
are accounting for so much sorrow and
unease in the world
and while the monster was the picture of
evil I really enjoy his motivation as a
character
piccolo Vegeta Frieza cells boo beerus
Frieza again we're all antagonists ahead
undisputably bad Morrow's going into the
fight with our heroes making it easier
for us to get he kinda likes of the Z
warriors but the monsters motivation was
in my opinion not as black and white as
the others in the past so much so that
it made me question which side I was on
aside he was angsty and radical yes but
at times there was truth to what he was
saying but this line by trunks added
much-needed perspective so there's
already tremendous scene with those
words a sword comprised of all the
energy on earth might be a bit
far-fetched but it facilitated a
gripping climax and capped off a truly
side-splitting scene is it going to be
hard to beat this one well number two
the cheeto first is the monster episode
66 many of you watching this - thoughts
is this particular scene should have
taken the top spot and honestly it was
extremely close so much so though I had
an entirely different draft but this was
my number one but a few things keep this
from being as gripping as the number one
entry in my opinion but for those
reasons I'll get to the later this scene
was brought to us by and large by the
wickedly talented neo kosher schita and
Masahiro Sheva new key let's talk about
Shimon new key before we get to shoot at
work Masahiro schooi new key was in
charge of the final kamehameha cut up
until this point I had lost focus even
if he had any great animation left in it
for the most part he has just drawn over
people's animation to correct the
character design to ensure that they
were my model but this scene is in my
information a big return to form for him
the blast explodes from ejidos kanji an
extremely fluid way and to think this
isn't even the best part of the entrance
nope that distinction goes to sheet I'm
afraid for those of you that are
familiar with shooters work you'll know
that he's responsible for some of
dragonballs greatest animation nothing
short of electrifying is used smoke
trails flash in color and life coupled
with this [ __ ] your pants let me off
this right speed of animation even when
they aren't moving they look like
they're going fast the standard of his
animations are
really high with a great deal of Polish
that said I did find a couple of things
in this scene that took from its overall
experience
when vegeto meets the master in midair
combat he'll and a couple of kicks
before bringing him down the kicks move
too quickly without any reaction or
impact animation on the Masters body
giving the kinks in no way looking as
though they're not hitting him at all
the final graph I had isn't an animation
error per se but continuity work as the
Chito grabs the master look at the hand
vegeto uses the playas head into the
floor but when we switch to this scene
almost immediately after it's a
different hand now this scene was
breathtaking awesome and all that good
stuff but there was still one that I
feel had the edge over all the rest but
before we get to that I think it's only
fair to shine a light on some of the
other amazing moments that didn't make
it onto this list are still worth
celebrating that's right it's time for
some honorable mentions
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
number one Goku and Trunks versus the
masu and black episode 57 that's right
it's Sheeta again having only
contributed two scenes to this arc he
managed this tonight in the top two
spots cementing his position is toe his
top animator effortlessly and it's hard
to argue with the quality he produces
grabbing the top spot is Goku and trunks
versus Amato and black from episode 57
filled with invasive back handsprings
she does signature dusters high paced
high flying action combined with his use
of camera angles force perspective and
breakneck animation effects build an
extremely satisfying experience oh and
his choreography is always the most
effective I believe the point of
choreography or storyboarding is to
convey the actions or story in an
interesting and easy-to-follow manner
there are some exceptions but generally
speaking that is what the desired
resulted no point did I get confused as
to where I was or what was the narrative
of the fight unlike some movies be it
Goku spin kick trunks coming to the aid
of Goku only to be intercepted by his
imasu the Instant Transmission
Goku black chasing Goku with ki blast it
just serves the further solidify my
point and wall Sheeta is the driving
force behind why this section takes the
number one spot Mullins such as this and
the excellently conveyed slow-motion
sequence only served to cut out and
already Hall of Fame or the entry this
seems biggest strength and really this
arc - I believe is that it leaves the
fans wanting more if you're watching the
show about fighting you should never get
tired of watching people fight and I for
one never did when I was watching this I
was always equally awaiting the next
episode eager actor made a similar
argument when discussing the legends of
Zelda franchise in his series t :
which I highly recommend you to check
out if you want to get into game design
but I digress the trick is to always
leave the fans wanting more and although
this art had some flesh to the moments
for sure I think it delivered on being
one of the most captivating and sapone
storylines in recent memory as it
pertains to the Dragon Ball franchise
it's easy to sit here and say this was
the best Dragon Ball super air so far I
don't think I need to convince anyone of
that and has it moved swiftly onward to
universal survival are only one thing is
for certain we are eagerly awaiting the
next exciting episode of Dragon Ball
and so concludes give another animated
moment top 10 list I really hope you
guys enjoyed it
apologies for the huge delay thank you
guys for all the comments messages and
support I read everything you write it
honestly couldn't have made it this far
without you more free time has been made
available in my life for YouTube so
expect another video much sooner but
until then I've been totally not mark
and as always thank you so much for
watching